egal wohin er fährt er verkündet die
botschaft des internets
in jedem menschen auch der regen kontakt
aufnehmen können
er gibt den selbsternannten experten ein
dolmetscher für alle die digitalisierung
immer noch nicht verstanden haben dafür
navigiert sich der 19 jährige durch
fremde städte sucht online öfter ein
hotel als den weg nach hause zu den
eltern haben buch geschrieben das heißt
wer wir sind und was wir wollen mit dem
untertitel ein digital native erklärt
seine generation und zwar ganz einfach
aus dem grund weil ich gesehen habe dass
bei ganz vielen menschen ganz großes
unverständnis herrscht über diese junge
generation die mit smartphones
aufgewachsen ist die scheinbar überhaupt
nicht mehr raus geht sich mit freunden
trifft sondern viel lieber in eine
virtuelle welt abtaucht das aber an
diesen vorurteilen nur ganz wenig dran
ist sondern dass er das gegenteil der
fall ist
darum geht es mir das aufzuklären die
teams sind natürlich nicht allein
laut einer amerikanischen studie die
philipp riederle gerne zitiert sollen
sich nutzer von facebook und twitter
weniger einsam fühlen
die virtuelle welt für ihn nur eine
erweiterung der real
das netz hat ihn bekannt gemacht
mit gerade 13 jahren zeigte wie man 2008
das erste iphone knackt seitdem
produziert er ein video nach dem anderen
inzwischen mit werbung wie ich damals
die ersten videos aufgenommen habe bei
der podcast da bin ich total um bedarf
daran gegangen ich habe die idee gehabt
ich möchte irgendwelchen leuten
mitteilen wie irgendetwas funktioniert
ich habe mir noch gar keine gedanken
gemacht was ich erzählen wissen ich habe
die kamera auf aufnahme gestellt und
dann einfach angefangen zu sprechen
das scheint gereicht zu haben 150.000
klicks pro video nun jettet viele
brüderle von einem gut bezahlten vortrag
zum anderen gestern werden
heute wien mit 15 jahren folgte zum
ersten mal eine einladung der deutschen
telekom schon als schüler berät er top
manager
sein thema wie das vernetzt sein und
arbeiten radikal verändert
heutzutage haben sich ja die technischen
rahmenbedingungen ein bisschen verändert
das heißt wenn ich für mich weiß dass
ich zwischen nachts 11 und morgens 4 uhr
am kreativsten und am effektivsten
denken und arbeiten kann
warum sollte ich mich dann irgendwie von
8 bis 4
irgendwo in einem miefigen betonbunker
einsparen das horrorszenario seiner
generation einen job ohne soundcheck für
seinen auftritt beim druckerhersteller
rico in österreich der abiturient soll
jetzt auf große veränderungen einstimmen
denn wer braucht in einer digitalen welt
noch kopierer und faxgeräte
wer druckt noch aus
wie ticken die kunden von morgen wie
wollen sie leben und arbeiten für die
ricoh mitarbeiter geht es um ihren
arbeitsplatz sie sollen mobiler werden
nicht mehr im unternehmen setzen
dahinter steckt der kostendruck der
geschäftsführer will so über eine
million euro einsparen
warum wir viele brauchen ist weil er für
diesen veränderungsprozess die herzen
und ohren unserer mitarbeiter öffnet und
erkennbar macht das arbeit in einem
digitalisierten zeitalter freude machen
kann und dass die angst und den
physischen arbeitsplatz bei weitem
wettgemacht werden kann dass die
freiheit die mobiles flexibles arbeiten
bieten kann
philipp riederle lebt das jeden tag und
versucht zumindest den einen oder
anderen skeptischen zuhörer in seiner
welt mitzunehmen
mit ihnen mitgeben
fort
ein